when Russia invaded it wasn't just
Ukraine being tested
the whole world faced a test for the
ages
Europe was being tested America was
being tested NATO is being tested all
democracies are being tested
and the questions we Face were as simple
as they were profound
would we respond
or would we look the other way would we
be strong
we're gonna be weak would be you we
would would we the all of our allies
would be United or divided
one year later we know the answer
we did respond we would be strong we
would be United and the world would not
look the other way
[Applause]
we also face fundamental questions
about the commitment to the most basic
of principles
would we stand
up for the sovereignty of nations would
we stand up for the right of people to
live free from naked aggression we stand
up for democracy
one year later
we know the answers
yes we would stand up for sovereignty
and we did
yes we would stand up for the right of
people to live free from aggression and
we did
and we would stand up for democracy and
and yesterday I had the honor to stand
with president zielinski and Cave to
declare that we will keep standing up
for these same things no matter what
[Applause]
when President Putin ordered his tanks
to roll in Ukraine
he thought
we would roll over
he was wrong
you ranked the Ukrainian people are too
brave
America Europe a coalition of Nations
for the Atlantic to the Pacific we were
too Unified
democracy was too strong
instead of an easy Victory he perceived
and predicted Putin left
with burnout tanks and Russia's forces
and delay into in disarray
he thought he'd get the finalization of
NATO
instead he got the natoization of
Finland
and Sweden
he thought NATO would fracture and
divide
instead NATO is more united and more
unified than ever than ever before
he thought he could weaponize energy
to crack your resolve your resolve
instead we're working together to end
Europe's dependence on Russell Russian
fossil fuels
he thought autocrats like himself were
tough
and leaders of democracy were soft
and then he met the Iron Will of America
in the Nations everywhere that refused
to accept the world governed by fear and
force
he found himself at war with a nation
led by a man whose courage would be
forged in Fire and steel president
zielinski
President Putin
President Putin is confronted with
something today that he didn't think was
possible a year ago
the Democracy of the world have grown
stronger
not weaker
but the autocrats of the world have
grown weaker not stronger
because in the moments of Greater people
and uncertainty
that knowing what you stand for is most
important and knowing who stands with
you makes all the difference
the people of Poland know that you know
that
in fact you know you know it better than
anyone here in Poland because that's
what solidarity means